why we must ensure not only a high-quality
and victorious confrontation on the front against
our enemy, but also the same struggle
with success must take place on the ideological front, the
dismantled parts are of historical
value, they are important from the point of view of
researching the period when for
40 years the coat of arms of the Soviet
Union was on the very  monument Well, of course,
from the point of view of historical research of the
era when Ukraine was part of the
Soviet Union,
wind and weather affect the lifting of the coat of arms.
and profile, then it
has a very big effect because it can change the
filter and there can be an accident